all right this is tragic and disturbing
news coming out of New York the body of
America's first Muslim woman judge an
African American woman was found in the
Hudson River
her name was judge Sheila Abdus Salam
and her body was found near a hundred
and thirty second Street in Hudson
Parkway she had been reported missing
earlier in the day by her husband and
later on on the day they found her body
washed up on the river police sources
are still investigating but as so far
they did not find any physical injuries
any signs of trauma which leads them to
believe that there was no foul play
here's a problem for me Pat and maybe
it's just the fact that I've watched too
much television growing up I've never
really heard of some but someone's body
just washing up on the river and it not
involved foul play
certainly very suspicious and because
there's so little evidence at this point
we don't know if it was a killing in the
first place but if it was a killing on
the basis of the fact that she's a
Muslim and yes you know she also black
and she's also a woman I don't think it
would have to be with those reasons but
yeah you know or maybe you know someone
that she convicted of a crime came back
later after they got out of prison yeah
and why there's all sort of so many
different possibilities when when you
are a judge I'm reminded of the judge
the other African American judge who was
killed this week shot in front of his
home in Cook County a Cook County judge
he was killed and they believe that it
could possibly be related to a robbery
but they also can't rule out the
possibility of previous convictions and
previous people who have been appeared
in front of him having some involvement
so two African American judges killed in
one week and and I have to be careful at
least the other one Selam judge at the
Salam
was found dead and there's no accurate
information as to whether or not she was
killed but just a little bit more about
judge abdus salam she was elected to the
Supreme Court in 1913 Court rather in
1993 she was appointed to the Court of
Appeals shortly thereafter which is of
course the state's highest court she was
appointed by Governor Andrew Cuomo in
2013 so you know this is a sad story no
matter the cause of her death but again
it's very very suspicious and and and I
I don't know I don't want to just
attribute this to TV culture but just in
culture in general I really rarely have
heard of anybody washing up on the
shores of a river not having something
to do with foul play there's a
possibility you know if it was a suicide
if there was an accident somewhere out
on the water it just it doesn't seem
like that would be likely
it doesn't seem and of course at this
point all we can do is speculate so we
won't do much more speculation but we
will say that of course this is a
tragedy we hate to see this this week to
see this just in general with anybody
you know but this is this is the second
death of a judge in in America and this
week this week alone and they both have
been African American so we'll keep our
eyes and ears to the news on this to see
any developments in that story